the evolutionary part is
i think hard to predict here and
anyway my bias too i'll be curious it's
a multivariate system yeah it's a highly
complex multivariate system yeah and uh
but i'm totally with him
that uh mass vaccination in the face of
this enormous amount of uh infectious
pressure yeah is uh
um
we could say madness
i think it's it's at the intersection of
ignorance and hubris it was wildly
reckless
um and i i think he was
i want to hesitate to say clearly but it
feels like he was quite right about the
driving of the proliferation of variants
and and so trying to be an objective uh
you know how it is in science yeah um uh
we we try to live in this world of
multiple working hypotheses and then
design experiments or look for natural
experiments to allow us to
to throw out
uh as many hypotheses as we can leaving
us with the one that we can't throw out
yeah as the probable um right um so uh
this uh
um
driving towards evolution of the escape
variant that is the omicron series let's
say
um
has
some anomalous findings associated with
it
that
get straight to your core competence
as you probably know when you build the
phylogenetic tree structure
for the relatedness of these viruses
using the standard software and i'm
choosing those words carefully yeah
and let's go back look back to that
moment using the standard software it
projects that the origin of the omicron
uh branch from that evolutionary tree
that we call sars kobe 2
uh
um
precedes
uh the evolutionary branch that gave
rise to for instance delta on the prior
variance
so that's a conundrum
uh how can that happen
one hypothesis that i'm aware of
is that and this will get to your again
to your core confidence i'm playing to
your your expertise
is as you know
evolution is not always linear in terms
of
changes over time in a given in a stable
ecosystem
in a stable niche
you can use uh
um base alterations as a sort of
molecular clock
right sort of i mean that all of these
molecular clock things have assumptions
in them that are big field of thumb at
best bingo and those
the best of my knowledge those core
models that are used are built on the
thesis
that that rate of molecular evolution in
a large viral population is relatively
consistent
and yet we know
um with our backgrounds in evolutionary
biology that in fact going back to
darwin's finches
that what often happens is when a
organism
encounters a new evolutionary niche yeah
it will undergo an explosive evolution
very right and all
presumptions we have about the rate of
evolution go straight out the door yep
um and and you have these evolutionary
bursts and that is really one of the big
stories of modern evolution of modern
evolutionary biology is the realization
that that you have these interactions
between niche availability and
evolutionary births and you can't make
those assumptions about constant rate of
evolution
and constant rate of molecular change so
it is possible
that
those phylogenetic trees
represent a artifact
of an underlying assumption in the
calculations having to do with the rate
of mutation
that um
uh
the thing that plays to that thesis
the supporting
data
in my mind
is that
concurrent with the emergence of omicron
with its
molecular characteristics and by the way
we don't characterize the glycosylation
pattern we just characterized the
protein sequence so that's a blind spot
we have
um is that
um omicron also was noted to have
shifted
its tissue targeting
now if you if you
pick at
with gert and you dive into this
he has uh a construction around
that that shift had to do with these
innate antibodies
that are non-blocking driving um that
evolutionary change
but for whatever reason
there was a shift in the tissue trophism
from deep lung which is known in flu and
other respiratory viruses to be
associated with a more highly pathogenic
virus and you can take an h1n1 this is
where where it was really made clear was
h1n1 has a variant that is very deep
lung targeting and it has another
variant that is not
that is more upper airway and
oropharyngeal and the one that is not
upper airway is less pathogenic um and
so omicron
concurrent with its emergence and its
incredible infectivity
uh has this shift
um from its tissue trophism to more of a
upper airway oropharyngeal which is why
the paradox of
it's more infectious and less pathogenic
which
on face when you look at that you go
what that doesn't make any sense at all
it had this shift and so that means if
we go back to the evolution yeah and
bursting
what something happened that caused it
to get a new niche
yes uh i would also point out this is
one of these places where i feel like um
the
the lack of transparency around
what was going on in wuhan that likely
produced this
is uh is criminal okay that's that's a
great segue to the third hypothesis well
hold on i just want to put this on the
table the point is
this virus ain't normal
absolutely it behaves so bizarrely and
the ways that it behaves bizarrely are
at least to some degree pretty easily
mapped onto hey we were doing some stuff
in the lab and we accidentally selected
for a bunch of other stuff along the way
because of course we were we
intentionally selected for it well they
no they intentionally selected for
certain things but if they ran serial
passage experiments in
ferrets and humanized mice in order to
make a
virus that was uh
humans more infectious in humans what
they did was accidentally trained it for
uh the ability to jump species
the the fact that they probably did it
and in in saying that you're giving the
benefit of the doubt just so we're clear
on that right
they also um
if you take let's say that they used
ferrets which seems likely given that
this virus actually does transmit
between individual ferrets and
individual minks to other ferrets and
minks
if you
cage minx together
and then you allow them to infect each
other
the natural rules that a virus would
evolve based on don't apply right a
ferret in the wild that is infected with
the virus the virus has an interest in
not wrecking the ferret because the
ferret has to be successful enough at
doing ferret stuff that it lives to
spread the virus and so take for example
the loss of sense of smell that seems to
come with covet so frequently
if you remove the sense of taste and
smell from a ferret in the wild it's
going to die yeah it's going to starve
very quickly because it depends on those
things to find food if you do it in a
cage where it's eating ferret chow
right then it can be falling all over
its neighbors infecting them and the
point is what that does to the virus
is it removes the value of being
efficient right if the virus gets spread
best when it infects only those tissues
involved in transmitting it and it
leaves the ferret otherwise intact if
that's a good virus in the wild in the
lab it's a very different thing and so
they're done so my point would be when
we're looking at omicron and delta and
saying it's funny because omicron isn't
the descendant of delta we're looking at
a virus that is likely that is more
likely than most viruses to have left
species could have easily leapt into
mice because it probably was already
trained in mice and so had some
experience there and left back that's
not something you would expect normally
but we have to leave that possibility
open in this case and then when you talk
about
it moving tissues within the body well
we've trained it to have this extremely
broad tropism whereas nature would have
narrowed that tropism and so we
shouldn't be too surprised by that
either so
my basic feeling is look we know a lot
about viral evolution we've got to be
really cautious about applying it to
this virus because we did funny things
to this virus that nobody has explained
to us yet fair enough
and and uh you just touched on the
fourth hypothesis
so the the third hypothesis with omicron
i think omicron is fascinating case
study
um in its emergence in this context um
and you know it's almost if you believe
in divine providence
it its occurrence last winter was pretty
close to divine providence if that's how
you're wired
um
but for those of us that have to
live in an analytical world of data that
we can perceive and analyze and we're
not
allowing ourselves to invoke the divine
as we try to logic our way through these
things
trying to yeah
uh i don't think you're going to offend
me
i'm trying to square the circle here
it's not the creator i'm worried about
yeah um
so in any case um
you mentioned
the
species of reservoir
and inner species transfer
which is absolutely one of the
hypotheses for emergence of omicron
particularly since it was detected in
africa
the contra positive for that
is that
it it was first detected that doesn't
mean it didn't
appear before then it was first detected
in these four diplomats
that had a
travel history that is not disclosed
but to the best of my knowledge three of
them were european and one of them was
asian
um
uh so
uh
it it formally since we know it infects
cats
um and it infects ungulates at ergo
white-tailed deer for example yep um
in in the context of of central africa
and southern africa there are plenty of
both
uh and not to mention the field mice and
everything else uh so it had a rich uh
um uh
palette of potential alternative hose
all right well i want to be careful
there because there's a there's an
important distinction that people
typically miss
this virus jumps to a huge range of
species we've seen that there are only a
few that it jumps successfully within
and it has to do both before this
becomes relevant to the story now i
think we've seen it in deer i'm not sure
we've seen it in
felix
we've seen replication between felids oh
i don't know that
i think i think it does um transmit
we've seen this in zoos
i know it transmits two cats i didn't
know that it transmitted i'm not sure
about from from feli to felid okay
certainly goes uh in weasels ferrets and
minx we've seen it um
i believe mice yes so anyway we've got a
group and that group is already large
enough to tell us something this is the
project of africa
yes yeah i'm trying to think are there
any
deals
yeah there are but they're uh they're
bovits not servants
but well we got the spring bucking like
yeah okay okay so
they're primarily bovines but
nonetheless a we've got a virus that's
really good at jumping between species
and has successfully jumped
once across the solar so the point not
to get too deep in the weeds the point
is that it is theoretically possible
that this thing could have uh moved from
a human host to an animal host evolved
there could have been an evolutionary
burst in the animal host and then
reinfected a human host
and been more adapted in terms of its
ability to replicate and displace the
dominant strains at the time and it
moved through africa into south africa
and then
in throughout the world or us it's
possible that the whole african link is
only the an artifact of having
particularly astute virologists in south
africa who happen to make be able to be
good at early detection yeah um so we
can't disambiguate those things the
other one that is the uh
conspiracy spooky version of this
so that third of the four hypotheses
um that i've heard uh repeatedly
from
uh
colleagues who have intelligence
community ties yeah and and i think we
need to for the audience we need to just
put a stake in the sand um
yes i have dealt with many people that
are in the intelligence community
including the cia i've actually been
partnered with one
in a prior corporation that we've set up
i've spoken about this in bobby's book
and one of the things that i know for a
fact
i've discussed in detail the training
that is performed
is that folks that are trained in the
intelligence community are trained liars
that's what they are they are trained to
be very adept liars so anytime i hear
anything from somebody that i know is of
the intelligence community as a culture
i know that
i really can't place any validity on
anything i hear and anything i hear has
to be triangulated so that's the prelude
to saying um what i hear from multiple
people
which may well just be an intelligence
ploy
is that there were multiple viruses
engineered in that wuhan lab by the
woman that is known as the bat lady
who had a prior title apparently that
specifically acknowledged her leadership
as being responsible for bioengineering
biologic weapons apparently this was her
job title
in chinese in some way
and that there was something in the
range of a dozen of these variants that
were generated
and the thesis is that the parental
omicron
may have been a may actually have been a
predecessor virus
which was part of the developmental
program and that those phylogenetic
trees actually are accurate
um and that it was
intentionally or inadvertently
uh released so that i think that in the
landscape of
uh the world that we now live in
as people committed to
um
a multiple working hypothesis approach
to trying to discern truth in biology
which i think you and i share yeah
uh
um and i'm referring to a science paper
first published in the 1800s
that's kind of become fundamental to
those of us you were mentioning the day
we need to retrain scientists
uh and and one of those things we need
to do is is make them read that damn
paper
so multiple working hypotheses i think
we have to acknowledge
in that spectrum of alternative
hypotheses
that omicron may also be synthetic
yeah that's that is a real possibility
and i would just add you know and i'm
i know nothing about whether this might
have happened but the dynamics of
omicron open the possibility that some
and by the way i would think this is
incredibly reckless too but that some
white hat entity
really you went there used that term i
was wondering i was i was trying not to
use that term because it evokes the
whole q anon world oh well i don't know
that it evokes the curation world but
the point is somebody that was sick and
tired of seeing the coveted catastrophe
unfold
could have released it was effectively i
think
i think it's a formal possibility and it
was it was odd um these things that come
out of bill gates mouth
sometimes i you just gotta wonder why is
he so darn predictive when and and that
uh after omicron emerged
um he gave interviews in which he was
advocating
for the development and there was a
programmatic initiative launched
for development of infectious vaccines
so
i need to
say here that i've done a lot of
thinking about infectious vaccines and i
can think of few ideas more dangerous
um because
what is totally irresponsible what is
inherent to such i mean you look you
could talk about hubris well hey it
raises all kinds of questions about
informed consent because you're going to
it's like informed consent doesn't
matter anymore right but the worst part
is at the point that you've created
something even if it behaves like a
beautiful vaccine even if it gives you
sterilizing immunity and it's uh safe
at the point that you have created a
vaccine that jumps from individual to
individual what you've done is invited
evolution to take that thing and modify
it into something else and and and you
and i that live in this uh
you know with with a daily awareness of
the insane complexity
not of biology just biology at the
organism level but biology at the system
level yeah of ecosystems
we're acutely aware that if you release
an agent like this
that already we know for example has a
ready ability to
migrate between species
um
their
that's why i get back to hubris
the the idea that is being promoted
by
uh various players including apparently
the chief science officer of the world
economic forum
that we can apply artificial
intelligence and other advanced digital
technologies to predicting the behavior
of complex biological systems
is incredibly naive and arrogant it's
nuts we are nowhere close
we are nowhere close and to think that
you've got it nailed down invites
exactly the kind of disaster that we're
facing and it gets to the culture
of um
uh
um
[Music]
the
community
that will engage in gain and function
research
right exactly
[Music]
you